okay so the boy season 3 is packed with
major twists mind-blowing moments and
gut-wrenching deaths that will tear your
insides apart like termites sneezed when
he was in you
it's one of my favorite seasons of all
time and when going back through it
there's a major scene that really stands
out this is the moment which homelander
fights soulja boy hughie and billy
bochier after the events of herogasm
what have you done
throughout this video we're gonna be
breaking down why it works so well all
the elements in it that build up to it
and the aftermath that it leaves for the
rest of the series before that though i
hope you can give me just 90 seconds of
your time to talk about our sponsors
displayed now if you want to stand out
from the rest of the boys don't be a
check out our sponsors displate the
website is over 1.3 million metal
posters that feature a range of brands
like marvel dc star wars and the boys so
you can make whatever room in your home
lander really stand out
absolutely love this boys one and
there's also this spider-man design that
i think is really worth picking up on
top of this they have a lot of cool
stranger things ones at the moment that
have just hit the site so turn it up to
11 and let's get to it now this plate is
different from your typical kind of
poster as they use a special magnetized
system to mount them on the wall not
only is every display printed on demand
but they also come with a fast delivery
system and they also get signed off
individually by a master of production
to ensure quality control they're also
printed in the eu with an expected 4-5
delivery day window so if you order them
now you can have them by the end of next
week they're a great way to help out the
environment as well as for every single
disc plate sold the company also
planetree so you're saving the planet as
well
who's the real heroes you are you chump
massive thank you to display for
sponsoring this video and right now
they're offering an amazing deal that
you can get to through the link in the
description it's much cheaper just
clicking that in the description rather
than going through google or the website
address directly so you will save some
money by just going there again the link
is in the description below so whether
you're just starting a collection now or
adding to an existing one make sure you
go there right now and check out these
amazing deals cheers okay so episode 6
was billed as being the big moment in
the boys season 3 where we'd finally see
hear orgasm go down if you read the
comics you'll know it's a major arc in
that which shows all the sadistic stuff
that the soups get up to when they're
not posing for cameras even people who
hadn't read the comics i think will
likely have had it hyped up for them
beforehand due to the word orgasm being
in it and the buzz on social media being
centered around it eric kripke had done
several interviews about it in the
build-up to the season and though it was
a big part of the episode i think in the
fight scene being the thing that people
talk about shows how much it
overshadowed everything else the three
seasons had built up to the battle
between butcher and homelander and
throughout this season we watched as the
former track down the quote-unquote
secret weapon that was capable of
killing him this was revealed to be
soldier boy a captain america parody who
himself had been souped up with bcl red
this was capable of killing the supes
and it finally seemed like hughie and
butcher had a chance of taking down the
worst of them now add to this the idea
of compound v24 a drug that had the
capability of giving someone superpowers
for a short time with this lethal
cocktail of the two elements it really
felt like the playing field was finally
levelled and that homeland out would
have a chance of being beaten once and
for all now this is given greater depth
by the way that the scene itself is
built up the entire event climaxes
with soulja boy unleashing his chest
laser which kills countless soups and
the ones at survival have badly burned
down to the balls looking at you love
sausage we then follow this up with the
moment which a train drags blue hawk
worse than i drag ryan airy and it
leaves the idea implanted in your mind
that there's actually a way to defeat
the soups never before have we seen so
many of them taken out and it
subconsciously gives the idea that
homelander has met his match now i
listen to a lot of podcasts when i'm not
at work and when the team are kind of
funny we're reviewing the episode they
said that it very much felt like a
season finale i completely agree and
this feels like it could end off the
entry with a big final battle between
the two sides the fight itself takes
place amongst the runes of the party
which makes it appear as a battleground
which we already know many suits have
died at now in order for the stakes to
be high we also need to see the enemy as
being as much of a threat as the rest of
the characters do this is cemented by
homelanders entrance we open this moment
with termite on the floor screaming out
for help and his boot comes down and
crushes him planting the idea in our
heads that this is what homelander is
going to do to billy and co tur might
also certainly hints to us that the rest
of the soups are like insects to
homeland there and then he has no
trouble taking them out what really
elevates this moment is that termite is
actually a character that we recognize
and though he's not exactly one of the
main characters i think he's certainly
one of the most memorable when we look
back on the boys in many years to come
and discuss the big moments in it i
think the termite scene early on in the
season will be one of those that pops up
it's nice that they actually set him up
with such a big scene so that when he's
squashed by homelander it's even more
impactful i'm gonna be honest yet
homelander is a villain that i love
hashtag heavy spoilers is how the party
begins but search your feelings you know
you love him too to me he's the reason
that people come back to this show every
week and i think that what has seen this
really well is that it also makes it
seem like he's gonna die so deep down
you're like no
get out of it now often in shows and
movies before there's a big defeat you
want the audience to have it in their
head that the tides are turning and it's
possible for the heroes to take out the
villain for example the end of return of
the jedi you have the rebels really put
on the back foot across all the battles
that are happening the battle of endor
looks like it's going the empire's way
out in the space fight we see that the
death star is fully operational and luke
is backed into a corner before he's
electrified by the emperor these are all
insurmountable odds and thus when the
heroes overcome and win in every single
circumstance it feels even more
exhilarating it's a technique used in
storytelling to make the battles feel
more enthralling and though it doesn't
happen per se in the boys they actually
flip the script when it comes to
homeland air because a lot of us deep
down want to see how far he can go we
want to see him survive this and come
out on top therefore when he's almost
beaten in the fight it feels even more
impactful because he's just managed to
escape what would have been certain
death for him it's very game of thrones
ian and now that show had a big falloff
come the final season i do still think
that on the whole it was a masterclass
in character development what they do
brilliantly in that series is that
they'd make you just as attached to the
villains as you are to the heroes so
that when they squared off you genuinely
didn't know who you wanted to win the
scene to me also feels very similar when
thanos is being held back during
infinity war it's taking all the might
of the heroes just to hold him down in
place showcasing how powerful he is they
almost have him and for a couple of
seconds you genuinely feel like he's out
the game before he manages to escape
[Music]
[Applause]
now on the other side of this you also
feel like butcher and co have just
missed their one big opportunity to take
him down this was very much an ambush in
which billy and hughie revealed that
they had powers that completely
blindsided the villain they'll never get
a chance like this again where they
catch him off guard like this and for
him to escape feels all the more
impactful because now homelander knows
they're coming for him and what they can
do as the old
you coming saying goes
you best not miss
this is why the end of the fight feels
so impactful because the three look
around like they've just messed up
massively even the framing of the shot
with them being shown inside the glass
homeland has just gone out of cements
that he managed to escape and leave them
and their ambitions behind it's
masterful and just the fight itself is
what really takes this to the next level
homelander says that he used to admire
soldier boy and he even has him against
the ropes until he's saved by butcher
you really have me going for a minute
there
boy
also on top of this just huey running
around naked like a headless chicken all
adds to the frantic feeling comedy and
chaotic nature of the battle to add to
it there's also what this scene means on
a symbolic level you very much have
archetypes here fighting it out for
their own ideals and their own beliefs
soulja boy very much represents the old
face of america that's battling for
relevancy and power in a world that's
changed idealistically homelander is the
new school inspired by the old but
taking things in a different direction
then we have butcher who is the person
that just wants to burn it all down and
get rid of both they all have their own
standings and stand for more than just
three people that's what makes this
fight so endearing we really have these
symbols all coming together for a good
old-fashioned showdown so we can see
who's gonna come out on top all this
adds to the fight being something
special and it very much sets up what's
to come in the remaining two episodes
that's what an episode like this should
do have you coming back for more every
week because you're desperate to see how
things turn out i feel this fight scene
definitely accomplishes that and it
stands for much more beyond just a
battle it's another reason why i
absolutely love the boys and i haven't
talked about this in a video yet but the
twitter account for the show even put
out the other day that they enjoy a good
theory time every time every time
really meant the world to me and i
couldn't have done it without you guys
checking out the breakdowns every week i
still want to do a couple more boys
videos the next one probably being about
whether black noir can come back so make
sure you stick around at the channel if
you're interested in that i'd also love
to hear your thoughts on the scene so
make sure you comment below and let me
know we're in a competition right now
giving away three copies of doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness on
the 15th of august and all you have to
do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the scene
you pick the comments at random on the
15th and the winners of the last one on
screen right now so if that's you then
message me on twitter at heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our season 4
theories which will be linked on screen
right now also huge shout outs to our
sponsors at display again for the
amazing metal posters definitely go
check out their deal in the description
below and with that out of the way
thanks for singing through the video i
mean poor i'll see you next time take
care peace